I think social networking is absolutely
here to stay now whether or not the
label will remain Facebook forever
depends in part I think on whether
facebook wants to try to be less
proprietary be more central to the
operation of defining and stewarding
identity online
what's going to be a person's anchor
point in this new virtual universe and
how easily can there be applications
that make use of that identity about our
features that we can control but how
easily can somebody author something new
and different for that and that's why to
me at the moment here in 2009 facebook
apps maybe aren't the biggest thing ever
but that's where I'd be keeping my eye
to see just how permanent something like
Facebook will be and it's also why I
think something like twitter has become
as i think for a lot of people
bafflingly popular as it has because it
is so commoditize abul it's basically a
standard for any one person or non
person to utter statements to the world
in short character bursts and that's the
kind of thing that can be built into any
other number of applications so I would
look next to see a whole range of
applications written that more innately
and automatically enhance or describe
our identities online as we just go
about our daily lives I mean right now
you see applications like Foursquare
metro and looped where people can say
where they are you check in at a
restaurant and then any of your friends
nearby know that you're at that
restaurant and could meet you there or
you connect it up with your social
network and now you can find among the
20 closest friends of your 20 closest
friends here is who else is nearby in
this restaurant you can greet each other
and meet without fear of one of you
being an ax murderer and we'll see more
of those services i think and more of
these kind of mouse droppings of just as
you act in the world right it's just one
more shift so you don't have to actually
check in at the restaurant but set it to
auto check in and so those with whom you
have a certain degree of friendship and
your profile automatically know where
you are at all times
as you go from one place to the next and
as more and more products have RFIDs
attached to them it can be effortless to
inform the world that you're having a
bowl of Lucky Charms cereal right now
because you were just handling the box
now is that a good thing I who cares
who's eating lucky charms but it always
starts with the trivial and the goofy
and then it turns out to have many more
powerful applications when you realize
for example that one of the biggest
barriers to successful health care is
whether or not people are taking their
medicine because it also turns out that
often they're sick what they're taking
their medicine and not fully of right
mind you start to see how I see bowl of
Lucky Charms who cares but did they take
their pills today much easier question
to answer in the 21st century than it
was